优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
好啦 再叫完再叫完再叫完
再叫完 有沒有聽到聲音啊
有沒有聽到聲音啊
有沒有聽到聲音啊 有聽到聲音幫我加個1啊
聽到聲音幫我加個1一下
好
聽到聲音幫我加個1啊
加個1加個1
我們最近的這個最近的績效很好啊績效很好這個先給各位看一下
我最近臉書發文的績效也不錯
我最近發文發到那個
那個什麼
那個聯合新聞網
聯合新聞網來
來引用了齁
發到聯合新聞網引用
聯合新聞網那個
各位看一下
找一下
找一下聯合新聞網的新聞
我覺得
這邊
聯合新聞網都來引用了
引用了
全正小哥
這裡啊
這個00981A
00981A我看
我看是
我看是有一個很大的問題
各位看一下這裡
其實不是他本色的問題
是規模的問題
只要一個股票
一個
一個ETF規模過大
這個會跟當年的0090會有點像
但是我覺得他比0090會更慘
為什麼
因為
因為他現在手上太多股票了
而且呢
他的股票呢
有些都是
你看你看這個
你看這檔台光店
台光店呢 各位啊 台光店
台光店呢
他近期來齁 他買很多台光店
好啦 那我們還是一樣
這個再介紹一下
我每天都會看的小雨的投資日記
好不好
以上小雨沒業配 好不好
小雨沒業配 沒業配我
他沒業配我 沒有啊
我只是 因為我每天會看他這個東西啊
他很認真做啊齁 所以我每天都看
各位來看一下喔 他今天的
他今天買股票我覺得相對的
呃...相對的
總覺得跟之前不大一樣
那我們來看一下09811他自己買什麼
來看他自己買什麼 哇小羽太認真了
這裡啊
各位看一下 台光店
台光店呢在昨天買了300張
三百張?你還拜託欸
欸 太光店四千八百塊三百張
你看有沒有有人講太小聲了很小聲了 等我一下我來看一下欸 拉到最高了
可以啦 應該
可以 聲音正常嗎
喔 各位
台光電
這個價格你敢
你敢買 你敢買
買幾張 我剛剛講幾張
三百張欸
欸 有沒有搞錯啊
他不是
這個各位看一下 300張欸
他買在這裡欸
買在這個地方買300張
300張欸他從來沒買
可能是同一啦可能同一買
喔
Maybe同一啦
我不知道是哪一個
Maybe
你看
喔呦最高點又買到喔
喔然後這邊
這裡買300張啊
有沒有
三百張啊 有沒有
你不覺得三百張有點多嗎
在這位置買三百張
那今天為什麼跌
各位今天為什麼跌啊
你想一下今天為什麼會跌
因為今天他沒有買啊
來來來我們再來看一下
我看一下我
我剛剛小雨跑去哪裡
小雨的這個來
今天他沒有買台光電了
好不好
今天沒有買台光店
一不買就容易跌
跟以前的那個
我們講高股息息很像嘛
要除息就買
除完息就不買
一不買就跌
那一樣啊
這個台光店
台光店很猛很厲害
這個投信啊
我們來看一下
投信好棒棒
這裡
投信一直買一直買
口口買
買到買了
沒錢買
沒有錢買了
就怎麼樣
沒有錢買
那可能又被別的頭戲賣嘛
一賣就一根黑K
好了 那再殺下去
你到底要不要
你要不要砍股票
所以你要想這個問題喔
再殺下去981要不要砍股票
你不砍
你的績效會開始落後一些
不要說大盤了啦
你可能會落後其他主動型一天
那這時候
哇 這時候就
就麻煩了喔
你的績效果開始落後
現在那個我跟各位講
哇 那個很多主動型ETF
都去電視台業配啊 為什麼
因為大家看到981這麼肥
這麼肥 太多人去買了這麼肥 想不到產物這麼愛就發了一堆主動型ETF所以呢你在店上面看到一堆業配哇 一頭拉股業配
這些業配都沒找我
好啦 反正你看到一頭拉股業配
一頭拉股業配
那這一頭拉股業配
為什麼應該看到981
很想基於它嘛 對不對
然後之後你就看到那個981
就開始跟其他ETF
這個我業配的話
我就很簡單嘛
我就把98IA的ETF绩效
跟我的ETF绩效两个一比
我只要怎么样 我只要赢他
我就说 你买98IA不如买我家的
我会讲 搞不好你就想跳槽
那你假如想跳槽呢
98IA就干嘛
98IA他就得
假如你跳槽 假如你卖98IA的话
他就得卖股票
一卖股票呢
各位啊 假如98IA开始卖股票
98IA是还没开始卖股票
但這兩天的籌碼呢 出現一個關鍵性的轉折啊
來吧 各位呢 請看我的文章啊
我們這文章寫得很專業 非常專業
今天比較晚開始呢 就是因為寫這麼專業的文章
你們給我看 我超忙 又要去錄影
錄影完之後 要寫這篇文章
寫這篇文章之後 直播 你看 籌碼
48小時的籌碼追蹤
因為我昨天我特別看98AA的
它的一些交割狀況
看98AA的交割狀況
那這裡
那各位看一下
981A呢 他在昨天的報表
他應付證券款是高達219億元
就是他要付219億元
他帳上現金153億元
各位你想想看 你敢做這事情嗎
你付投153億 你敢買219億嗎
你敢嗎 你一定不敢
因為你怕違約交割 對不對
那為什麼他敢
因為他知道明天還會有交割款進來
他明天還會有新的錢進來
為什麼明天有新的錢進來
因為昨天有人買他的ETF
所以明天會有新的錢進來
你懂我意思嗎
我把我圖片放大一點
好
因為昨天有人買他的ETF
所以明天會有新的錢進來
明天會有新的錢進來
那有新的錢進來他就不怕
所以買多一點你懂我意思嗎
就像說
你4月30號買股票
假設4月30號5月1號5月2號
5月1號領薪水嘛
所以5月2號我就錢交割嘛對不對
就類似這樣子嘛 所以他敢買
好啦 就昨天這樣子喔
他上現金153億
可是他買了交個款219億
然後4月28號
他的規模居然才增加了
才增加了
增加多少
各位你看一下
他前天規模增加200億
前天規模增加200億
為什麼 因為他應付證券款就200億了
你買200億當然增加200億啊
那你現在 今天怎麼樣
今天規模232億增到2357億
單日僅增加36億
就僅增加一點點而已啊
那現金水會暴增
照現金大幅回升到271
為什麼
因為他發現買981的人變少了
那為什麼買981的人變少
因為現在一堆人還去申購了什麼00403
00403A嘛
403嘛 對吧 應該沒記錯吧
然後呢 第一個 一堆人去申購
主動ETM 然後錢卡在那邊
錢卡在那邊
不能拿出來嘛
因為你去申購就不能拿出來
對不對
錢卡在那邊不能拿出來 這是第一個申購嘛
啊第二個怎麼樣
一堆申購去買這個
啊第二個呢
你要不要看一下很恐怖的這東西啊
喔 這裡這裡這裡
起保護術啊
這什麼東西啊
我們看一下這裡
嚇死人啊
有沒有看到 有沒有看到這邊
真恐怖啊 這裡
說一下說一下 這裡這裡
對
喔各位看一下
這才恐怖啊這個這個這個超恐怖啊
啊
這邊我是覺得很恐怖啊
有沒有看到
你看這什麼鬼啊
49萬人到6-7萬人啊現在
全世界各地全台灣的人沒買酒吧應該是怎麼了啊
欸一個禮拜增加多少啊18
18萬戶啊
增加了30幾趴
我沒有看過一個禮拜幾百戶數增加這麼多啊
你知道嗎
我沒有看過幾百戶數一個禮拜可以增加這麼
這麼
這麼多戶
這麼高的趴數
這一看就是
典型的怎麼樣
典型的最後那種
FOMO那種感覺啊
我帶一波風就像019世銀一樣
019世銀呢在當時
一段跑進去開戶啊
那時候我覺得019世銀完蛋了
太多人開戶就是問題這不是981A的問題 是規模的問題你規模過大後面就有個問題有什麼問題只要這個規模沒辦法再持續嘛只要沒辦法再持續 沒有新的人進來
你沒有錢再買股票
你沒有錢再買股票 你勢必只能換股
再跟各位講一次喔 你勢必只能換股
那當你換股你要怎麼換 我問你要怎麼換
你買了一堆台光電 好不好
你現在981買了一堆台光電
沒辦法玩
你買4800你要砍4000
欸今天多少
今天多少
昨天買4800今天剩4300
噢靠噢
好恐怖
昨天買4800今天剩4300欸
買300張欸買300張今天賠多少
各位你們要算看看
買300張一張賠30萬
今天就賠1億啦
1億很少啦
2000多億才賠1億而已
很少啦有沒有看到
2000多億才賠1億啊
腰池金母 很多人在拜
對啊
這很少嘛 才1
1很少
可是你
可是我問你要砍他嗎
你砍他有人接嗎 各位啊
這投信買成這樣
這砍了要找誰來接啊
你有沒有想過這問題啊
這砍了找誰來接 找外資來接嗎
外資要嗎
外資今天砍
投信砍
投信砍 外資砍
今天主力變大賣
一根大AK
981還沒砍
最近981買最兇的他啊
買最兇他
另外買一檔
各位等著看
這檔叫南電
好不好
南電充滿本來就沒有很好
都被頭戲買上去的啊
頭戲買啊
為什麼要買
我不買我的績輸人家
你懂我意思嗎
我不買我績輸人嘛
對不對
我買了我績績才贏人家
我不買我績績就輸人家
那我只好買啊
那等到怎麼樣
等到誰開第一槍
好啦 我問你 981A 它有規模減少了
它要賣什麼股票
你要不要去看它的成分股
它的成分股
我來看一下
來來
教各位看一下成分股
來 我找一下
我來找一下成分股給各位看
00981A的成分股
成分股蠻多的啦
來來 各位看一下這個基金投資組合
這裡
這裡齁
來 各位看一下
他今天啊 因付交割款這個一百這個一百七八億啊帳上現金兩百七十億昨天沒那麼多錢為什麼今天那麼多錢
為什麼今天那麼多錢
為什麼不大買
各位你要想個問題
這種就是他
他已經知道他未來的錢沒那麼多了
所以他沒辦法再買這麼多了
然後台光店買到四千多張
四千多張
藍店買到一萬兩千張
是藍店特別好
那你可以買星星啊 你幹嘛買藍店
你把藍店買到天上去
以前星星贏藍店20塊
結果星星被關 投信不能買
被關不能買嘛
現在搞的藍店比星星多100塊
這合理嗎
他就是因為星星被關 投信不能買
他就瘋狂買藍店嘛
那買到那個本益比不曉得
這到底幾倍啊
這93.9倍 這什麼鬼
對 本益比93.9倍 值率0.21%
那當然是 彩版未來是很好嘛
那未來很好 但是籌碼是沒有很好啦
籌碼外資都還賣 都你頭信買的啊
對不對 啊這種東西
這種未來很好 各位 未來很好 你比得不過威剛嗎
各位 你比得不過威剛嗎
欸 人家威剛 這一季賺多少 你要看一下嗎
你贏得了威剛嗎 各位 威剛這一季賺多少
欸 他不是EPS公告嗎
這個看一下
第一季我記得公告啦
好像三十幾塊啦
這裡啊
等一下我今天有看到一個新聞啊
第一季好像三十幾塊
欸啊 跑去哪裡啊
這我今天看到一個新聞 第一季三十幾塊嘛
你贏得了威剛嗎 對不對
這才猛好不好
威剛這一年賺一百塊
我覺得應該沒什麼問題啊
他一月份都賺10塊了
三個月賺三幾塊很正常嘛 對不對
你贏得了威剛嗎
那威剛為什麼最近會跌
為什麼 因為籌碼不好嘛
那籌碼沉澱完之後又開始變好了
就是籌碼沉澱要把線洗掉
那最近走勢又開始變好
為什麼 因為基本面太強勁了嘛
好 那現在問題是
第一個 藍店
藍店你的籌碼有好嗎
沒有很好
對不對 為什麼
為什麼 因為你看
主力都一買一賣嘛
一買一賣視為出貨
對不對 一買一賣視為出貨
昨晚沒有很好嘛那為什麼他股價那麼高投資買的嘛981A批命買啊好啦 等到有一天 不要等到有一天啦今天981就沒買了好不好
今天981就沒買了
沒錢買了 對不對
買股票還得賣股票了
好不好
今天已經到那個買股票還得賣股票了
買股票還得賣股票這種狀況
所以呢
所以
我們再來看一下小雨的
這個
買股票得賣股票
來來
各位看
不過他今天還不算明顯
今天還不算明顯
但是我覺得
我覺得未來可能常會遇到這種狀況
來來來
今天環球機一次就要賣458張
環球機賣33
順打賣458張
一賣就要賣到變0張
為什麼一賣要變0張
他砍股票他要一次砍到底喔
為什麼要這樣子
他不得不這樣子啦
因為他砍一半是要被人家痛載啊
他砍一半
喂 砍在這裡
他砍一半要被人家痛載嗎
你懂嗎
我砍一半不是告訴人家
糟糕天下說我明天還要再砍一半
你懂我意思嗎
我要糟糕人家說我明天還要再砍一半
所以呢他直接怎麼樣
他直接一次砍
一次砍完
這個環球機還算賣得不錯啊
好啦 那之後各位你等著看他成分股
看他成分股怎麼賣
看他成分股怎麼賣 因為
未來呢 未來我跟各位講
這個之前的績效齁
之前的績效是之前的績效
我再跟各位講一次齁
這個之前的主動型ETF他績效特別好
齁
再跟各位講 歷史統計以來
歷史統計以來 當然有人說台灣潛碟市場
美國是不是潛碟市場
你去看美國
美國的主動型ETF
它是比市值型ETF來的差
平均來說比市值型ETF來的差
那為什麼現在主動型ETF這麼強
因為台灣是個潛碟市場
你只要有錢進來
他就自己買
好不好
不要說搖遲金母啊
你給我2000億
我批皮買好不好
我就一直買一趟
我就一直買股票
我一直買
整個我的禁止不用買上去了嘛
你買我股票
我去买我的成分股
我的成分股涨了之后
你又觉得我绩效很好
对 你觉得我绩效很好
你又买我股票
我去买成分股
你又觉得我绩效很好
因为我去买成分股
然後股票又漲了
然後那個鏡子又漲了
你又覺得有績效很好
你又買股股票
好,這是不是個良性循環
那等到有一天哪一天
這兩天
好不好,這兩天你會有點
你會覺得有點怪怪的
你會有點怪怪的,為什麼
因為這兩天啊,各位看一下
9801A,各位看一下
第一個,它的線型有點變
這個呢,在我們的
黑K
這邊出現
離開上通道黑K出現兩次
第一個這樣 第二個是
你會覺得 欸為什麼
欸為什麼
為什麼我的股票
我的981A不是很強嗎 為什麼輸給大盤
為什麼昨天大盤漲684點
為什麼我的981A為什麼漲那麼一點點
為什麼漲那麼一點點
這個我早就跟你講了
我早就跟你講 我早就寫了
我都寫出來了
這裡...這邊...來...
這有寫啦
我寫來...看這篇文章
最近專門寫好文章
沒認真寫啊
一認真寫 你看這個
分享的多少
分享181 按讚3685
按讚超多
這個我在4月26號早上
這是禮拜天的早上 我就告訴你
明天是台積電一個人的武林啊
你等著看
都玩台積電
台積電一個人50
中小型股怎麼樣
中小型股很慘啊
資金排擠可以動消費
散物的恐慌情況
反而拉大促小
你看昨天的
那個昨天的怎麼樣
昨天的中小型的股票很慘
開高走低的一堆
跌停的一堆
好不好 跌停的一堆
那我們看到這些跌停的
我們去做什麼事啊
來 給各位看
我昨天呢 我去敲了兩檔跌停
我昨天我敲了兩檔跌停
第一檔叫做6451的訊星KY
這檔跌停我敲的好不好
我把它敲開
昨天把它敲開啊
昨天敲開
這單要敲開的好不好
這個是停損哥的紅包
停損哥是誰呢
停損哥
我還是不要講好了
這個公開平台不要講太多
有興趣去我的PP看好不好
這我PP看就講了
我就說訊星有停損哥的紅包啊
好不好 停損哥賣股票
那是給我們上車的啊
昨天講了 停損哥賣股票因為停停損完了就是會漲嘛各位你懂嗎 大戶停損完就是會漲好不好大戶停損完就是會漲
再跟各位講一次 大戶停損完就會漲
你有看到這一段的 幫我加個1
幫我加個1
我昨天那個
這個
訊星KY
大概買了
八十幾張
我買八十幾張 我有貼啊
我有貼在那個
貼 貼 貼 貼 貼 貼 我找一下
昨天有貼 我找一下那張圖啊
我想要把它找出來
這個我就說啊 這個訊息KY啊
這個
這個點啊 這個點很值得啊
這個 欸 挺損欸
各位 主力沒大賣的跌停你還不買
而且你有機會敲開的
我有機會敲開的
我昨天我敲開的
我就是我敲開的
我敲哪一盤
我敲這一盤
因為這盤一看就知道會開了嘛
所以我敲這一盤
這四盤我都不買
我就買了這個點
只要跌停會敲開
各位要勇敢敲
那你說那敲開再鎖上去怎麼辦
鎖上去就鎖啦
對不對
你敲十檔有一檔會鎖
九檔不會鎖你還是要敲啊
你懂我意思嗎
敲十檔有一檔會
有一檔
即便有一檔會鎖
有十檔不會鎖
你還是得敲啊
你懂嗎
找不到那個
各位的那個直播的留言
看一下留言跑去哪
再跟各位講一次
敲十檔會鎖
你還是得敲開
哇這邊一堆加一
各位都看到了
我看到了停筍哥的紅包
停筍哥的紅包很那個啊
停筍哥的紅包
很甜
好不好 很甜
第一個 停筍哥的紅包
欸 我昨天買到 三流二
八十幾張嘛 我記得買八十幾張
等一下 我找一下
我好像圖還沒找到 我昨天有貼啊
我昨天有貼在那個
我們的VIP群裡面啊
我找一下
先找一下
我先找VIP群
因為我們那個處置VIP群
我昨天有貼 但是我不是盤中貼的
因為我不想要影響盤中的狀況
我是盤後貼盤後貼 來來來我給各位看那個我這群啊我這群來來來來來找一下
昨天盤後貼
盤後貼就是告訴大家怎麼
我們教的處置很好用啦
對
來 別怪
唉唷 跑去哪
等一下 我把這個拉出來
我看能不能把它拉出來
我怎麼讓他彈出來
彈出來的視窗
找不到彈出來的視窗
沒關系
來來來
我們這個是學人聊天
學人聊天來
我先找一下這個處置群
處置群的聊天
來來
來來來
這邊
太多了太多了
這個盤中我是沒什麼聊
盤中這個
昨天
這邊有沒有看到
這裡啊
訓金84張嘛
有沒有84張
84張
90張538
370張136
好不好
欸各位
不用怕
我都沒在怕了對不對
84張這裡啊
這裡啊 各位看一下
84張
裡面可能還有一些其他的
反正這邊
這個價位我不知道買了幾張我忘記了
有啦 反正就362嘛
金價363
對不對
各位你看今天多少
405這樣多少
40塊
4萬嘛
484張
300多萬
有沒有
有沒有看到300多萬
然後懷雨呢
懷語是538,4991懷語538
538,我昨天在群組來講,欸538
538這麼甜,欸538不買
這裡,我買這一根,這我買的
這裡我買的啊,173張我佔了多少,我佔了
90張
這邊173張我買了90張啊
173買90張,為什麼要買,因為這根有開啊
這根有開幹嘛不買
對不對
沒開把它敲到開
沒開敲到開
538好不好
今天多少今天627538627 這樣多少就 90塊嘛538627 90塊
90塊 90張
90塊90張多少
800 好不好 我們這兩檔就
就那個啦
這兩檔就
就破千了嘛 對不對 就破千了
那我們還有304
304的位置多好 我在
兩個禮拜前直播就跟你講了好不好
兩個禮拜前直播 有沒有
各位兩個禮拜前直播是不是跟你講
說經濟我們希望它處置
好不好 處置
拉回讓我們幹嘛 拉回讓我們做多好不好
那時候不是有跟各位講
經濟就是處置 有沒有
有聽到這一段 各位加個一好不好
有聽到這一段加個一
經濟處置拉回讓我們做多嘛
對不對 是不是有跟各位講
對不對
結果人家就處置啦 也拉回啦
有拉回你不買
對不對 136塊
我買136
有沒有 各位加1
兩個禮拜前跟各位講啦
對不對 兩個禮拜前直播跟你講
沒關係 經濟關了沒關係
最好是回檔讓我做多
有沒有 那時候
好啦 現在那個買了
370張
136好不好
136 那現在多少
現在149了
149了好不好
13塊
500萬
對
這個
都跟各位講了嘛
對不對
這些就是處置戰法嘛
對不對 各位
處置戰法
處置戰法 為什麼可以用處置戰法
就是
各位有沒有看到這VIP群
這VIP群是
那個500人
500人 目前滿滿的
因為這是第一群
這是上處置課的VIP
然後呢 我每個月呢
會錄一段影片
就是來複習一下
這個月的那些組織的戰績
那各位你看一下這三檔
你就知道這個戰績很恐怖啦
好不好 這戰績
我們是把賺錢的
把賺錢的方法分享給各位好不好
把賺錢的方法分享給各位
那這種分享對績效是有害的
再跟各位講
對績效有害的 為什麼有害
你買了我就沒得買了嘛
所以對績效有害啊 對不對
你懂我意思嗎
我們兩個都買同樣的價格
有可能我買不到啊
對不對 我那個 我敲
假設昨天啊 假設昨天
那個 這個價格
這個價格 那個
假設這個價格
我們來看一下421這個價格
全部人都跟我敲這個價格
我問你啊
全部人跟我敲這個價格
那我買的到 我不一定買的到啊
對不對 每個人都掛570我就買不到啦
我買不到538啊 對不對
但是我們還是把方法給交了
為什麼要交
因為我希望各位可以賺錢嘛
就這樣而已啊
我希望各位可以賺錢
我們把好的方法交給各位
那我們第一批500群的
500群的
第一批VIP群的
前200名每個人還送他一支日本娃娃
然後最近的心得就是怎樣
哇 一對很開心
因為第一個他收到日本娃娃
第二個他怎樣
第一個收到日本娃娃
第二個他最近處置的績效做得特別好
因為最近處置就很好做啊
最近处置很好做
在跟我讲
很好做
处置很好做
最近特别好做
特别好做
就是呢 该跌而跌 该涨一涨
最近很好做
所以呢 你假如按照我们的方式
按照我们的方式
那个
好好做的话
按照我们的方式好好做的话
其实这个是会让你获利的
而且呢 這種波動又很大
波動很大 但是
基於公開平台 我還是不要講太多
好不好 我們要把一些方式留給
把一些賺錢的方法
留給這些買軟體的人
買軟體 因為買軟體嘛 他付費了
他付費了
他付費了總是 第一個
買軟體要怎麼樣
買軟體很重要就是 你要讓人家有賺錢啊
你買軟體不賺錢 明年
明年不續約了對不對
然後在外面開始罵你
說賣什麼爛東西 害我賺不了錢
對不對
你懂我意思嗎
就像有的人去加會員
加會員沒賺錢就會罵人啊
加會員就沒賺錢對不對
買軟體你好好用的話
你會不會賺錢 當然會賺錢
好不好
為什麼會賺錢
因為我現在賺錢
我不賺錢我就跟你講說
這個方法不能用了 不會賺了
我會跟你講
我現在都一直在用啊
對不對一直在用
對不對我的買點就是我們的那個處置國裡面的訊號讓子回頭的訊號對不對 讓子回頭訊號
好
小哥不要講太多啦
對呀你看
所有上過課的人
再跟各位講一次
都會這樣講
我還冷氣看
所有上過課的人都說
小哥不要講太多
不要講太多
好不好
盒子賺錢還賺翻 已賺回軟體錢
最近浪子會有真的很棒 小哥別再說處置股
你看一對一對講 不要再說了
好不好
不要再說了 所以我們公開講了 不能講太多
不能講太多
趕快加入
加入那個啦 加入我們的討論群啦
好不好 加入討論群 加討論群不用錢
好不好
加討論群不用錢
哇 四月大賺五十幾 太好了
除了神器太好用 哇 恭喜恭喜
欸 這個都不是我們say的喔
好不好 我們不會去say 沒空say好不好
沒空say
你不相信算了 不相信
再見再見再見
最好不要相信好不好
趕快離開 趕快滑走滑走滑走
離開 離開 離開 離開
離開我的頻道
不相信我 趕快離開
算明趕快走好不好
我不想跟你分享賺錢的方法
一點都不想好不好
一點都不想
你不想相信 趕快走
你說小哥叫這爛東西 趕快走
好不好
我都貼對帳單給你看了
而且我們就昨天貼
我昨天是下午3點半貼
我就貼這一段
各位有沒有看到
來來來 我昨天
我昨天下午3點
又跑掉了
又跑掉又要滑了
反正我昨天是下午
下午3點多貼的啦
下午3點多貼的
底下又寫說有賺錢
欸 密碼
欸 密碼是嗎
密碼我忘記了
沒問小語
小語密碼多啊 我忘記了
小語
小語講一下密碼
306 306
好 等一下
好
經濟回頭 浪子回頭 賺
經濟浪子回頭 賺十幾萬了
哇 多少
今天出一口信心可以去30年生
哈哈
我們以後神器續約很便宜啦
好不好
第一年比較貴
因為第一年有賠跑嘛那後面續約比較便宜那最近在市場上賣呢呃又比較貴因為我們是限時那個處置神器這很好用啦
裡面很多教學好不好 各位很多教學
處置神器很多教學
今天是
直播快閃限定
我們先工商服務一下
因為今天又有人問我啦
小哥今天有沒有那個
有沒有比較便宜
因為那個沒有活動的時候他們就賣比較貴
賣5萬多 今天有活動就賣比較便宜
各位
這個給自己一個機會嘛
反正你看留言區啦
我跟你講不好的話就一對人在那邊罵
怎麼爛軟體
不要再開這直播
開始再嗆了
唉呦有人不開心了
我跟你講一定會不開心的啦
為什麼
因為
好東西不想跟人家分享啦
他們就想自己用就好了
自己用就好 小哥別再說了
好啦各位 有要買的自己買好不好
不要講太多
直播快閃限定
這邊啊 這邊有
那裡面呢
經接版FillIP 手機優惠價是15000
第二期去年價是16888
所以第二期之後
就變得很便宜啦
很便宜
第二期他就
僅限軟體全線續約
第二期就是只有軟體啦
那我們這一期呢 我們會有
會有陪跑啦
陪跑就是我跟各位講說
我最近在做什麼樣的交易
那我們有
基礎處置 進階處置 雙刀戰法
每月實戰陪跑 專屬討論群組
跟同策略的
不能賣的比前面便宜
沒有啦 這跟 這
這不是前面的價格嗎
欸沒有 這應該比前面便宜啦
比前面貴啦 比前面貴
對吧 比前面貴
喔
這比千變貴
這餵那樣夠嗎
欸 被我吃的話可能會不夠啦
夠啦夠啦 我留一些給各位吃啊
各位 我那個訓星我也沒吃完啊
對不對 這個環宇我還
我還剩一半給你吃啊
我又沒把它吃完 好不好
環宇我才買90張啊 他成交178張我才買90張而已
對不對 來這裡啊
環宇啊 欸環宇你是吃的完膩
來 173我才買90而已啊
他有83張給你買啊 對不對
你買到這盤多漂亮
這五張不能買 跟各位講 這五張不能買
因為這五張不會開你不能買五張的他搞不好當天都鎖死 鎖死隔天還開低所以買這一盤是不治的但買這一盤是很重要買這盤可以買
買這一盤可以買
那這五張不能買
那173我才買90張嘛
你看我佔90張
那剩下83張
可不好其他血緣的啊
對不對 又不是我的
好不好
對啊 那我買90張
那今天就爆噴了
來 今天
環宇呢 我就賣掉一些了
賣掉一些了 為什麼
因為它漲停啊 我已經獲利十幾%幹嘛不賣
處置我的抓的停利點大概就10%以上
10%以上我就分批停利了
那假如它走勢比較弱 5%我就停利一些
那通常10%以上我大概會停利個七八成
那後面看有沒有機會20% 30%
像我旺宏有吃到30%
好 那這些績效 我們在前幾天呢
來來給各位看 我在前幾天 我有貼我的績效
我有貼啊
來來來來給各位看一下 我可以貼的績效
這邊啊這邊
這裡有貼啊這裡
這裡有貼啊
來
我貼 這一天是那個
4月23號
今天是23到禮拜四嘛
禮拜四呢各位看這邊賺596萬
193萬258萬
那加壓就破錢
就是我們這邊大部分都是做處置的啊
你看這邊有新興嘛
那這個可成新興嘛對不對
新興這個有做啊
做藍店賠錢
反正這邊加壓是1000啦
那這一天呢
這一天我們在幹嘛
這一天我們在吃火鍋
喔 這邊蠻好玩的
這邊吃火鍋 這邊 這裡
我們跟一群人吃火鍋啊
跟一群人吃火鍋在這邊
對 我們去吃朝廷火鍋
欸 我們講一下火鍋啦
這個火鍋喔 真的
我大概一個禮拜吃個三四天
三四天 那為什麼
為什麼要吃火鍋吃三四天
第一個 因為它的那個
它的肉啊
跟各位講 這裡面的肉每個都原肉
原肉啊 它絕對不會是組合肉
然後呢 這邊的湯呢 那邊湯喔
那边汤这个汤呢
你吃完你出门
你不会有那个
身上火锅
身上不会有火锅味
不会有火锅味
然后吃完回去就觉得很舒服
不像有些店
有些店我觉得人
人工的東西太多啦
反正這邊吃起來東西都很天然
然後它的食材呢
它都是買比較好的
就像你在裡面吃的蛤蜊啊
蚵仔
我問老闆說
你這蚵仔你怎麼買
為什麼那麼鮮甜
他說
因為那個大盤商跟他說
蚵仔有四種等級
問他有哪個等級
他就買最貴的那個等級
買最貴的那個等級
所以呢這個
這個食材真的很好
我覺得吃這種又
又怎樣
又怎樣 又健康
不用過多調味料 我常常吃都沒有蘸醬
就只有湯的那個
我們就找了一群學員來這邊聚會
好不好
各位 你找一群學員聚會
我問你 你曾幾何時你聽到
那個有老師找一群
那個會員來聚會
你們聽過 可能有啦 可能有
可是以前我聽過一個故事
我覺得蠻恐怖的
他說以前有個老師
我在檯面上很有名的老師
這以前過的老師
出門要帶八個保票
八個保票
因為太常幫主力出貨了
所以呢這個出門帶八個保票
那我們都教各位賺錢方法
所以我們就比較沒有這種
沒有這種那個
我們就沒有這種顧慮啦
這些學員 但是賺錢才會來嗎
不賺錢連你都不想理你好不好
不賺錢的時候退訂了好不好
這些學員有的人都是跟我跟十幾年的
跟十幾年的
好啦
好啦好啦
好啦 我們再回來
再回來
再回來講
來啊
這個處置
欸 處置神器web版
會在五月中旬問世啊
五月中旬問世
那PVIP學員可以搶先體驗
他有即時監測預設提醒還有數據分析
那個這個
呃 怎麼新的各位可以自己去
欸 就可以自己研究啦
剛購買可以加LINE
可以啊
購買我們都會幫各位加群組啦
我們還有第二群
第二群人數比較少一點
那以後我就盡量兩邊都找機會跟各位聊一下
我的處置的一些戰績啦
處置的戰績
跟各位 給各位看一下
我買了什麼
我買了什麼 理由什麼
各位 我講的理由很簡單嘛
主力沒大賣嘛
主力沒大賣回延到月線嘛
這個
這不是講了很多次了嗎
重點什麼 重點要有人通知你啊
喔 啊這處置神器他會通知你啊
他會通知你什麼他會通知你浪子回頭來來來來來來給各位看一下來來來欸
我
我給各位看一下
這個處置神器啦
喔
給你看一下
給你噴噴一下齁
給你噴噴一下
這個讓子回頭啊
好
我來看一下
唉這邊
這個環宇啦環宇今天就先訊號啦訊號就要賣了
處置回檔後漲10%啊
他回檔後漲10%得宏處置回檔後漲10%
永光處置回檔後漲10%
你看到沒有啊
這麼大隻漲10%我們都買不到
對不對東山再起這邊一堆啊
這邊一堆啊 今天一堆嘛 對不對
昨天殺勇敢買 今天一堆處置回答後漲10%
現在買的就一堆啊 對不對
自勝IT 潛頂永光德榮 環宇KY
你看這邊一堆啊 這都今天的訊號啊
10小時前
10小時前 他告訴你 處置回答後漲10%
東山再起 信昌店 齊邦 鼎原
鼎原 巨漢 雅電 今天一堆東山再起啊
昨天一堆浪子回頭啊
我今天有浪子回頭打航啊
處置回頭4956
昨天一堆浪子回頭
今天今天今天
哇經濟
今天今天今天今天
今天今天今天我有看一下我沒買
這個不是說出現訊號就買喔
但你要出現訊號你要判斷一下
判斷一下說籌碼好不好
很簡單嘛你就點進來看啊
點進來看就好了
點進來看這個主力買來抄嘛
懂我意思嗎
點進來看就可以
或者怎麼樣 或者你可以直接用這個看啊
來這邊 點進來啊 你看K線
K線有沒有看到主力買賣鈔 有沒有看到這一條線
看來這個問餒啊 主力買賣鈔
啊疊下來主力又沒跑 主力沒跑就是要東山再起啊
你有看過主力沒跑 然後主力難道不會自救嗎
對不對 主力當然要自救啊
欸主力沒跑 沒自救是怎麼做啊
要等自救嘛 對不對
所以他就容易東山再起嘛 所以
不是我有多厲害啊
是
是那個
讓子回頭玩就容易東山再起嘛對不對你看這個處置回想後長時間你看這邊有多少好不好好 然後我們再看昨天的訊號昨天的訊號呢 是一天前
一天前啊
浪子回頭氣棒
浪子回頭永光
經濟儲置後跌20%還不買
好不好 看到儲置後跌20%
這不是天上掉下來的禮物嗎
你還不買 看到這訊號你還不買
儲置後跌20%
對不對
欸在一個那個國度裡假如沒有處置的話
對不對 沒有處置的話
他根本不會跌啊
對不對啊這個有處置跌
啊經濟以後會出關啊 欸經濟會出關啊餒
對不對 出關餒 之後會出關餒
他現在已經到第六天了餒
我要等四天餒
有沒有
後面剩四天餒
對不對啊這個
就這樣子啊 反正我們看到浪子回頭
然後就讓我回頭
看到主之後跌20%
我們就再看一下籌碼
你要做的SOP很簡單啦
再跟各位講
要做SOP很簡單
你呢
就是呢
看到訊號
然後看到訊號
浪子回頭了嘛
主之後跌20%了
打開K線看一下
看這個主力這條線
看你滿不滿意
開不開心
喜不喜歡
好不好
喜歡
就勇敢買進
好不好
這個我們買過很多啦
這種只要籌碼不錯的
籌碼不錯的
10檔9檔會反彈
好不好
只要籌碼不錯
再跟各位講
只要籌碼不錯的
10檔9檔會反彈
反彈你就賣就好啦
反正賺10%就賣啊
對不對
就好啦
10%就賣了
就賺了
就這樣了
哇
有人跟我一起跳開訊息
同一個時間點
就這樣
就這麼簡單
好不好
而且這很好
10分鐘裁判 好不好
不用緊張的鑰匙
每分每秒都很緊張
有人做當中
有的人說小哥當中好難喔
你來做處置
你不要做當中好不好
你來做處置就好了
當中一秒鐘跳那麼多下太難了
這處置20分鐘跳一下
好不好 20分鐘跳一下
好
20分鐘跳一下給你慢慢買
有沒有看到
20分鐘跳一個讓你慢慢買
20分鐘
昨天隨便買好不好
好不好 讓你慢慢買
然後組織還有很多進階的
那進階我們就不要講了好不好再講下去講下去旁邊留言區一堆人抗議欸你不要再說啊好不好你越講越多不要再講啊就這樣不要講我們是把賺錢的方法分享給各位
我不要講太多
不要講太多
要就
加入
那個處置神器
不然就算了沒關係
要不要加入都可以啦
我們只是分享賺錢的方法
這方法真的很好
這我是覺得我們這個處置成績已經做的
做的
喝口水
我們把很多knowhow都寫進去了
然後呢裡面還有雙刀戰法
我覺得雙刀戰法這個也是一絕啦
也是一絕
我們用雙刀戰法呢
做了很多交易
就是有時候你做
單做處置你可能怕怕的
但是你做雙刀呢就比較沒那麼怕
就一多一空啦
就一多一空
做一多一功能就比較沒辦法
像我的這個星星藍店
我一直在做雙刀
一直拆一直解
反正就很好玩啦
好不好
就很好玩
好
那
儲置的統計這樣子啦
我們看一下
來來來來看
來看一下儲置的統計
來來來來
反正儲置很好玩啦
很好玩
那儲置呢就是
一開始組織會跌嘛 後面就容易漲嘛
就這麼簡單嘛 所以
所以拉回呢 就是
反正你要記得 統計學上
拉回就是讓你上車的啦
這就是統計好不好
那你這個統計是這樣子的
那遇到統計的那個偏離這麼多
例如說原本統計只跌一天
它跌了三天你還不買
它跌一天後面都容易漲了
它跌三天你還不買
那不是
那是天上掉下來的禮物嗎
你懂我意思嗎 對不對
你看304
第三個黑K不是讓你買的嗎
對不對
4991這不是讓你買的嗎
黑K不是讓你買的嗎
然後呢
訊星
訊星幾號
瞬間忘記
訊訊
訊星
欸
太興奮了
訊星突然忘記
明明就買很多
6451啊
你自己看嘛
對不對
這不是讓你買的啊
對不對 645一樣
對啊
好
現在是四萬五啊 比手購貴啊
沒辦法 因為手購是鐵粉嘛
有的人連介紹都沒介紹
我們在講一些 有些學演喔
連介紹都沒介紹喔
只是一上家就買了
欸你也等我介紹一下
對不對 你沒有等我介紹你就買
小哥 反正你說什麼我就買什麼
我說不是這樣 你要知道說
我們那個三萬多塊裡面含什麼東西
那所以呢 一開始就買的
一開始就買的
我就覺得一開始就買
我們就送你200隻娃娃
這個送到我現在庫存
沒什麼日本娃娃
這個要找時間去日本補貨了
找時間去日本補貨
那第二個這重點是有陪跑
就是我們會在每個月
你就想像整理每個月
後來會有一個教學
教學讓你看一下
這整個月的處置股長怎樣
我四月份我就把
這四月份的處置股長怎樣
全部讓你復盤讓你看一次
好不好讓你看一次
那你看完之後你就知道說
喔 原來儲置股是長這樣子的
齁 那你多看你就知道
喔 原來做股票是會賺錢的齁
來來來 我們看一下
欸 宣戰機放起來 宣戰機
等一下 屋子有沒有放上去啊
好
等一下 屋子有沒有把儲置放上去啊
喔這裡這裡
欸 不是不是
這裡這裡 喔這裡這裡
這個是我們從群組裡面撈的
我叫那個
請小雨幫我撈的
你自己看
大量買一張而已 我賺10萬
學完儲之後打地槍不但賺人學來
倒賺一倍學會回來
安儲息喔
欸對不對對不對
這也是大量
唉唷 他的點一樣欸
一樣
因為
這個就是
蕩紙威頭啊
各位你看一下
31674月28號這裡啊
大量我買我買五張
我記得我買五張賺
然後這裡嗎
這邊欸等一下看起來
他們賺了哪個今天
這個4月28號我4月28號才賣喔
喔4月28號4月28
喔今天等一下可能抓今天的資料
這裡啊
喔昨天那個點很漂亮啊所以今天賣沒錯
今天賣沒錯啊
有沒有今天賣很好啊今天賣很好來看一下這學人賺錢我們教的是方法啦
好不好 教方法 不是報名牌
唉呦 用權證參與也可以
這個有權證還是可以買權證
有權證可以買權證
謝小哥是我吃酸喔
這個穿跟喝 東山在起是我的出場訊
我就按照據
有10% 你各位就不用擔心了
有10%就很多了 就很多了
這是賺到新興
硬能
喔
硬能我
我多空都賺 空不要講太多
台耀有
謝小哥教育上次買的處置回檔 今天是入袋
大銀為系統
這每次一賺齁 當然就10%
因為東山再起就是10%以上的訊號
就10%以上的訊號
還有1個那個
這個是寫的
確認心
這邊大量
謝謝小哥數字的教學
宇氈牽點
就這樣
這個主自然
類似信德再太多了
我們只是截取部分的 其實心得很多很多
可是你在群組你就知道了
群組不是騙人 500 個人
來
各位
這群組阿
喔
這群組來 以個別視聰開啟
來 看到了
有沒有 五百人
沒人離開啦
爛東西早就離開了啦
爛東西早就離開了
然後他們會互相討論啦
其實我聊天聊的比較少
因為我聊天聊比較少
Po個
Po個寫的文章
但聊天聊不多啦
他們裡面就互相大家研究
有沒有
500人
沒有人離開啊
加入他捨得離開啊 對不對
就這樣啊
齁
好
所以各位
呃有興趣的
可以加入我們的
處置神器好不好
他是
我是覺得勝率非常高啦
勝率非常高
真的
齁然後他就
就賣這兩天
之後要買又變原價了
喔原價比較貴好不好
原價比較貴
好 那
欸 做處置
你剛剛看我堆上單你就知道了啊 我剛剛那個
我們看還宇 還宇就多少了
這裡啊 還宇昨天買90張買在這個位置 昨天買90張買在這個位置4991這裡這裡啊懷疑昨天買90張買在這個位置昨天買90張買在這個位置4991這裡這裡
買90張買在這個位置
買在
昨天買在這個位置
買在敲開的位置538
買538你看今天這樣子
這樣子多好對不對
啊這個
就把好的方法交給各位
以後看到訊號
這個籌碼不錯的話 環宇籌碼就不錯啊
你要勇敢的買 好不好
勇敢的買 這以後都有這種機會 要勇敢的買進
勇敢買進 遇到這種機會 要勇敢買進
不要害怕
不要害怕 你看到環宇
這處置回來 你看這處置回來 跌幾%
這處置從725這樣跌下來 跌幾%
這本來就是很適合的買點啊
3042也是很適合的買點嘛
對不對這邊也是超市的
這個下影音多麼值得買啊
這都很靠近月線的
阻力還在買
你看到股價下跌
這典型的價籌備理啊
價格往下籌碼往上
這本來就是個好買點啊
我們在以前就預測跟各位講說
這裡會出現一個很好的買點
你一定要記得上車啊
你還記得我們上次跟各位講2337啊
對 望虹
說這個回檔
這個時候也是處置啊
這裡是一個超級好的買點 你要上車啊
我一上車我就賺了30%嘛
對不對 以上賺了30%
後面最高點賣
不是最高點 我賣在152吧
後面這邊賣152啊
後面跌回來就不關我的事了
反正我就是
我就賣152就賣完了
好 以勝才
好 來 各位你看以勝
以勝你說得很慘嗎
以勝事實上你有一個
那個將近10%讓你跑
看你有沒有跑
因為靠近月線是在這裡
1 2 3嘛 你假如在這個靠近月線這個位置
這位置買大概是
買在110左右
因為這個這邊位置你會買在靠近月線這點嘛
那彈上來的話 欸各位你假如賣110的話
到這位置本來就是漲10%啦
到這位置又漲10% 只是看你要不要跑而已啊
你懂我意思嗎
所以你看以剩有人獲利7%有人賺錢啊
那你說他很慘
他也沒有很慘 他是有機會讓你跑的
只是看你有沒有跑掉啊
以剩我有跑掉啊
以剩我有跑到啊看你要不要跑嘛 對不對因為我們這種有點像搶一堂嘛有10%讓你跑 你不跑以剩有的買108以剩獲利出獎 對不對
你說以剩很慘好不好
你在想那麼多圖子裡面
你好不容易搶到一堂
以剩很慘
還是一堆獲利啊
所以你知道
按照期望值來說
按照統計學來說
它就是一個高獲利的一個交易嘛
就這樣嘛
喔 處置全陣怎麼挑選喔
嗯
處置全陣喔
一樣挑全陣的方法啦 好不好
好 沒關係我教各位一次 好 來來
我教各位一次啦齁 處置全陣怎麼挑
這裡這裡
喔 全陣怎麼挑呢 我們要打開一下
打開挑選全陣小幫手喔 好不好
打開挑選全陣小幫手喔
喔 來來來來
那因為處置的時候呢 這個權證呢都沒有都沒有很好買
好不好 因為很多
造勢商不好的造勢啦
所以都沒有很好買
那我舉來說啦齁 這個
他跑第一趟的時候
跑第一趟的時候呢 可能就資料比較
還沒出來齁
好 我舉來說啦齁
我舉來說像經濟 我看經濟有沒有權證
好 有權證 哇 慘欸
我都差點比小一啦 我覺得小一比較好
有這幾檔啊 可以啊 可以啊
你買之前喔 你要記得喔 各位
買全證喔 全證現在有
有壞蛋呢 會做什麼事啊
會把全證買完
例如說像這個流通比98%
他把全證買完之後自己造勢
自己在高檔造勢
那怕各位買到那個
不合理的全證喔
所以呢流通比太高的不要買
齁再跟各位講
流通比太高的不要買
那流通比太高你真的想買沒關係
你看一下微賣引波至少不要
突然上升很多
你上升很多就很恐怖啦
那種全震就是
你到後來要賣都沒得賣
好不好
所以呢
你最好買那個流通比不要太多的
那插槓比低
各位插槓比是第一要件
插槓比要低
那第二個呢微賣引波要穩定
這個就算穩定
你說疊下來上去沒關係
這個還是穩定
有突然接下來都沒關係
他只要是長期這個穩定就好
你不要越來越高就好
所以這個影波這個算穩定
那你看他講原本都79
現在這邊看到是80
那這應該沒問題
這應該是券商的肇事單
可能是啦
不然就券商肇事單可能也沒有離很遠
那我們就看啦
像這個
呃...這個應該
欸...不確定是不是
這邊呢
呃...可能是啦
國票的影響波動力會一直降
我就比較不喜歡
國票的就沒那麼穩定啦
啊...元大的相對穩定
各位 你就買元大啦
你會怕你就買元大好不好
元大呢你可以上網查
好不好
這元大呢我還是比較推崇他啦
這一集元大沒業配
再跟各位講元大沒有業配
沒有業配喔
元大要業配也可以找我啦好不好
元大元大乾爹可以找我業配
但這一集他沒有業配
064253各位
上元大全正網看一下064253
看一下
他會告訴你微滿波動率80%
他告訴你啊 80%
那我現在看一下買價波動率 79.97%
沒問題 這1.29是他的
他會負責
他會負責這個80%的波動率
他會負責 各位不用擔心
他會問 明天會不會自己改成79%
理論上不會啦
理論上我覺得不會啦
那各位記得
那個只要微買波動率沒有掉
你各位看 80% 沒錯嘛
這價格他的
只要1.29是他的
你就不用怕了
因為至少有1.29回收嘛
對不對 然後這邊
1.32
欸他盤中應該是大概差兩個tick啦
我們從這裡看得出來嗎
差兩個tick我覺得還算可以啦
還可以
因為差兩個tick呢他的差更比大概在
大概在0.4左右啦
其實我覺得差更比在0.5以下我覺得
在儲置股都算蠻好的
所以各位小資組呢你可以利用儲置股
來讓你翻身 為什麼 因為
因為你買權陣
你頂多等幾天 你等沒幾天啊
那儲置股呢 大概就10天嘛
那10天呢 它都有一天
它可能會有一兩天 它就噴出讓你跑啊
你懂我意思嗎 它噴出讓你跑
儲置適合上班族嗎 非常適合 為什麼
當中才不是的嘛 儲置每20分鐘一次啊
對不對 老闆不爽你 一直看股票
你說老闆讓我20分鐘看一眼 可以嗎
呵呵
20分鐘看一眼 可以吧
各位你可以玩20分鐘的啊 5分鐘的不要玩啊20分鐘讓你開一眼 好不好 20分鐘不然就20分鐘去尿個尿老闆你是不是憑尿 我可以20分鐘尿一下
久久看一下嘛 咕咕咕一次的啊
20分鐘看一下就好了啊
20分鐘一次廁所
可以啦 20分鐘我覺得可以啦
我覺得20分鐘蠻好玩的啦 真的啦
呵呵呵
好啦 就這樣啦 我覺得這個還不錯啦
很好玩啦
很好玩 所以我覺得
這個比較適合他們 因為他的節奏比較慢
當衝那個太快了啦
各位 最近一堆違約交割
好不好
違約交割幹嘛 有的放空的 有的做多的
一堆違約交割
那違約交割就是
就是每個人不想認輸嘛
一堆人不想認輸啊
所以你看 一堆違約交割
這一堆啊
再跟各位講一次
微焦哥呢 各位 什麼時候微焦哥很多
我不曉得各位還有沒有印象
什麼時候微焦哥很多
在那個 這邊有一堆微焦哥啊
穩茂微焦哥啊 連兩天翻車啊
穩茂抱微焦哥啊
好不好 這裡啊 連兩天翻車 3105
通常微焦哥要嘛大漲要嘛大跌啦
都這樣
就大行情啦 大行情每個人不願認輸啦
喔 啊這個看起來是做多的死了
做多死了嗎
知道嗎
這是做多啊 信化也有在違約啊
這信化是不是買錯啦
17000 喔靠 現在17000了
好久沒看17000了 沒有注意到
對不對
微焦哥 信化重買不好
那充滿不好
齁
啊這種微焦哥
做多當衝啊
我覺得跟各位講當衝真的很難啊
當衝很難
當衝真的很難
好不好
各位我沒有很鼓勵你當衝
你當衝
拚了老半天
賺的要死要活賺個一趴兩趴
你賺個一趴兩趴
你要不要來看一下
各位來來來來
你賺一趴兩趴
加加加 來 各位看一下
你自己看
東山再起 各位 我們的訊號是這樣子
你要有浪子回頭才有東山再起
所以這裡雅電就是你前幾天你就會看到雅電再跟各位講一次你這裡看到雅電浪子回頭出現已漲10%
就是你一定有看到雅電的浪子回頭
城市這麼寫的
我們不會像那個
有些老師說
恭喜會員
這張股票漲停板
老師我怎麼沒有漲停板
是不是我的會員等級不夠
阿對啦對啦 你會員等級不夠啦 你要加入總統會員
我們不是投顧老師說 也沒有 我們不是投顧老師齁
再跟各位講一次 我們不是投顧老師
他只會通知你 讓紙回頭
阿讓紙回頭
他通知你了 你自己再去看一下 好不好 你自己再看一下
看一下籌碼好不好 啊這很簡單嘛
點一下籌碼好不好 籌碼不錯
你就可以買嘛 就這樣子
然後呢 他東山再起在通知你 欸東山再起 欸咋趴咋趴
你每天做當衝
賺都賺一頓啊
賺都賺一點點
賺一點點一賠賠屁股
對不對
賠到微焦哥
你不如來玩這個嘛
對不對
沒錢怎麼辦
沒錢買全證啊
買全證也可以啊
對不對
當衝績績只有一兩%
我跟各位講一兩%算很好了
一兩%算很好了啦
因為當衝你是來回一直刷 一兩一直刷
一兩%這好啊
我當衝平均一% 我那天都覺得我好開心
你懂嗎 因為我們是來回一直刷嘛
來回一直刷量做很大 那一%很恐怖耶
我們平常成交量一天都是上億耶
我只曉得一億做當衝的一%是多少錢
各位你有沒有想過這個問題
一億做當衝的一%是多少
他有時候一天做3億5億的
1億的1%是多少
1億的1%來回5000萬嘛
5000萬的1%多少 就50萬了捏
當沖1%
哇 涼風吹 我玩當沖狂陪 玩儲製大賺
真的啊 儲製比較簡單啊
當沖很難啊 真的很難 當沖很難
當沖很難
但是我還是喜歡當沖
我是盤沖當沖 儲製都會做啦
但是我覺得處置很好玩
而且最近處置特別好玩所以我最近處置做比較大好不好 你看我部位你就知道我處置變大了嘛處置變大 當中有時候就是做個人情嘛
對啊 昨天吃飯對不對
然後那個
這個某公司的協理工程
欸 小哥 我現在要期末考
沒有 要期末考
反正就是要評鑑
要評鑑了 倒沙缸一下
喔 是是是
對啊 就是幫人家一下嘛
做個業績對不對
有的主管要評見
你做個業績啊
人家比較好升官
我遇過很多經理人
都有跟我做過這種拜託啦
有拜託我就
我就有可以的範圍
我就加減做嘛
我就做啦 不是加減做
可以的範圍我就做這樣
可以幫就幫嘛
反正我們盤中會看全方位
我看全方位的顏色啦
其實我當中
現在當中有一檔股票很好衝
叫做00981A
00981A超好充的
因為它有量很大
我就看這顏色
看這顏色變化的時候
我去做00981A
那你也可以看它成分股
像今天成分股台風電跌最多
所以它表現就沒那麼好
那
這個
反正這個當充很多方法
但是
可以跟我講
當充還是比較難
要賺一2% 你買了賺了10% 這每一人都10%啊
每一人都10%啊 對不對
這怎麼都10% 有沒有
這全部都10% 有沒有 有沒有看到
都10%
浪子回頭跟你講
跌下來跟你講
跌20%跟你講
這通知啊 通知會告訴你
這通知多嗎 最近比較多啦
但是 因為最近盤比較好
所以最近玩處置很好玩
很好玩啊
除了權政以外 儲置可以用 也可以用期貨啊
也可以用現股啊 可以啦
可以用很多東西啊 好不好
儲置可以用很多東西
齁
這個也可以用零股 真的啊
因為儲置很多高價股啊
我之前儲置我買一檔
喔 買一兩張
買三張而已 齁 賺了
賺了好多啊
這邊啊 這裡有沒有
這裡啊 這邊銀威啊 這裡
你看這邊 我就有買六千多啊
沒幾天一萬塊
沒有一天一萬塊
對不對
好啦
欸
第一次直播一段時間我不要再講了
有沒有看到
大家都是那個
大家都是為自己著想啦
不要不要再說啦 好不好
好的方法不要再講了
不要再散播出去了 好不好
我們來談得好啊
好啊
所以不相信我的 趕快滑開
趕快滑開
不要相信我 好不好
這個不要相信我 都騙人了
這都騙人了 不要相信我
好啦 相信的喔 相信的再工商一下
好不好 處置神器
他只開放兩天
4月29號 兩天嘛
兩天之後呢 他就又恢復原價了
原價又很貴 又5萬多塊了
又5萬多塊了
第一次當主會頭買幾萬不回
看籌碼狀況 籌碼很好 我就買多一點
籌碼不好 我就買少一點
目前賣 陳俊明不要自己
現在講
資金不夠 資金不夠沒有關係
這個反正這個策略呢都
呃...都一直在啦
存夠錢再來買就可以
那這個
這東西是要隔日沖的
所以你還是要一點本錢啊
因為它跟當沖不一樣
它要隔日沖
那但是隔日沖我覺得你可以買權證嘛
權證不用花很多錢
第一個可以買權證
第二個可以買零股
好不好
像銀衛一對買零股嘛
藝人科技一對買零股嘛
你會有一堆零股可以買
現在買零股越方便了
那你目標就是10%好不好
目標10%
10%很驚人喔
各位 你一個月
你一個月假如平均10%
它也不是一個月10%
它不是平均
但是你常常遇到10%啊
所以我處置我一直在換股
我一直在換
這樣賺10%我就換另外一檔
那反正每天都有訊號嘛 對不對
所以呢我就會換另外一檔
有賺我就換另外一檔
所以呢這個滾下去
我是覺得他的報酬力還不錯
我就這樣
所以這儲置很值得一玩啦
大多頭才有得用
空頭
空頭裡面儲置都沒什麼儲置
好不好
裡面儲置股票都變少了
那空頭不會很長啦
大多頭真的很好用
真的很好用
古奇也可以
標的不多
快下播
夜深了
一直叫我下播怎樣啊
就不能多講兩句
好啦
所以處置神器可以幫助你喔第一個我們有處置日報處置日報他會告訴你說明天什麼股票比較危險啊那其實我都是用這個這個來做當衝的交易
我也常教各位
其實用儲治日報來做當衝
其實勝率很高
儲治預報來做當衝
儲治日報做當衝勝率很高
那
那我就不要講太多了好不好
不要講太多
這個
這個你上PP我
PP每天都來講啊
我說我今天做這一檔
為什麼
就是因為儲治日報
都講嘛 反正這裡面都有
好不好 裡面都有
那組織組監控
那監控呢 會讓你看喔
這個
會讓你看一個東西啊
來來來
再給各位 再偷看一個東西啊
好不好
再給各位看一個東西啊
來啦
給你看一下我怎麼買的好不好
來來來 我怎麼買的
自選股
這個我怎麼買的
我從儲置做好中去買的啦
好不好
儲置做好鐘去買的
我從裡面去買的
那有沒有
欸 儲面這樣
把它滑掉一下
各位你假如覺得
怪怪的你就把它滑掉
從儲置做好鐘去買的
那這裡面呢 會有一些
它那個有些技術面的
一些訊號
唉唷
跑得有點慢
這邊
儲置做好鐘
這裡面會有技術面的訊號
位階月斜啦
通常我喜歡找那個位階低到高的
那我們找月線協力會要找正的
找正的喔 富的不要找
跟各位講 富的不要找 為什麼
因為富的代表說他可是弱勢股
我們找強勢股 位階低的
強勢股位階低的喔
跟各位講 昨天讓什麼訊心 還語
經濟都從那裡面找的啦
這個
什麼東西
以後要開放抖內嗎
不用抖內啊 自己賺就好了
抖內幹嘛
我什麼時候開抖內的
我們直播不開抖內的 自己賺就好了
做教育自己賺就好了
好啦好啦好啦
這個一堆人叫我下播
好 就這樣 處置神器喔 各位記得
這個
有 要買趕快買
來
那
處置一些比較中心核心的思想 其實
那個我們課堂上都有講 現在課堂上呢
就是反正你
你訂了處置神器 裡面都有一堆教學
齁 那除了教學以外呢 還有每個月的教學
每個月還在上一次課每個月上一次課然後這裡面的課已經很完整了反正都在裡面好不好都在裡面
好 那最後呢我們有
這個股票起貨十三班
台中高雄台北廠
歡迎各位來上啦
PPIP的各位再買一次
不用啦
有買過就好了 不用再買一次啦
小哥培跑課
他們上完字幕就上啦
我今天路樓都上了
好不好
刀神器開不了
就滑一下就開了
欸
上錯啊沒有公布
好好好
差點忘了公布
來來來這裡
跟著小哥學會雙刀幹法真的改觀了
配合處置神器掃標跌
無論行情怎麼碰怎麼跌
配對交易讓人很安心
兩邊賺的機會也變多
真的
真的很好用
好不好
雙刀戰法
好
很
慶幸交易路上小客單,小客客不只刷新我智慧
更傳說很多實用的真功夫
實用的啦,你看誰
你看誰用自己教的方法
還買一堆股票的,對不對
自己教的方法
自己教的方法,找標的自己教的方法
買股票,還買給你看
對不對
還讓你看說我買什麼股票,對不對
還告訴你,對不對
啊,就
就這樣啊 就是我們都是教自己賺錢的方法
你來上課你就知道我教賺錢的方法
我教...那我不會賺錢的方法
我就不會教了 我就不會教那麼多年的好不好
教那麼多年為什麼人家跟那麼久啊
就是因為他有賺錢他才跟那麼久啊 對不對
直播客沒上到有重播
有啊 都有重播
齁 都有重播啊
3081符合位置嗎
3081有儲置嗎
3081又沒儲置
好不好
再加上平常直播的無私分享給我們一顆定性玩
就這樣
招式很多啦
真的
好
來 中獎名單這樣子
然後呢
這個
股票期貨13班
各位呢 這個籌碼K線研究分點
有需要的可以在這邊購買
13個月
送443檔的
低買高賣的大陸分點清單
這裡
嗯
當成績真的很棒
真的 真的也很棒
真的
好
那全球交易筆記本
這是九折優惠券啦歡迎各位訂閱我們裡面每天都會告訴你我在當中什麼標的當中很難啦但是我處置有一個人會講我在買什麼股票
那訊息KY呢
其實在前一天我就講說
訊息KY很甜好不好
很甜
訊息KY超級甜
這個有停損哥的紅包啊
很甜好不好
訊息KY有停損哥
這個就是前一天我們在那個
因為前一天我們就發現有人在停損了
我在這天發現有人在停損
然後就跟學生講
這停筍的紅包很甜
這上次已經甜過一次了
這甜到有口碑的好不好
這停筍歌甜到有口碑的
我們在P就跟各位講
隔天我就大買
我就買八十幾張
三千多萬
買八十幾張三千多萬
這很讚啊 真的
小哥10點了
一霸不能
說到這不是百分百勝
我目前大概是百分百勝
這順利真的很高
喔 真的很高
好
就這樣了
好啦
有需要可以購買
欸然後最後
呃
這個PBR就這樣喔
這邊
九折優惠券
然後
這邊呢
這個還沒加入群組可以加
密碼
我忘記了
喔
好不好
喔 唉唷 小明珠也叫我下播
好 OK 差不多了 差不多了
我們要走了 我們要走了
小明珠要下班了
來 古曜奇波時在班台灣上 幾要上課
喔 幾要上課 各位打一下 打一下
喔 打一下
來 幾要上課
幾要上課 齁
來 各位打一下
我要來那個 我要
欸 我也叫個
我來
線上亂數產生器啊
亂數產生器
又是旅遊
賺錢就是要出去玩好不好
賺錢就出去玩
來80號
好
這個請小秘書找出人的啦
好啦
那喜歡今天直播呢
歡迎按讚訂閱留言觀看心得
這個抽吉米花跟哪裡
各位啊我們可以抽這一隻喔
哇先
先去小愛心夾到
夾到他調台了
調台
喔因為
這個他覺得我太強了
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕